[Music]  5 26 on your monday morning was driving  me crazy well the expired tag  conversation continues  bob weighs in i see dozens of cars every  week with paper tags a month or more  past due i even saw one that expired in  march of 2020 over two years ago how  much money is the state losing from  these scoff laws  and diane's on that same page asking me  to please include in your report the  loss of revenue  yeah so besides law enforcement and how  they deal with this issue apparently  it's time to see if the nevada  department of motor vehicles and maybe  even indot want to weigh in so stay  tuned for the next episode of as the  expired tags turn  thanks again to bob diane and everybody  who's written out on this topic buckle  up drive carefully please put down that  phone  join the drive in you crazy conversation  at traffic eight at eight news now dot  com